Last time I lectured under the illusion that all you had been assigned for,
I really should get in the habit of looking at the syllabus that all your,
all you had been assigned for Thursday's lecture was the,
so sir,
uh,
Lo and behold,
I did take a glance at the syllabus over the weekend and realize that you'd also
been assigned to Levy Strauss.
Uh,
so we have a little bit of ground to cover today.
I think we can do it.
Uh,
I think I want to reserve,
um,
something like a critique of structuralism for the beginning of Thursday's
lecture because it segues very nicely into what we'll have to say about Derrida.
I already promised that somehow or another,
the creek critique of structuralism just was deconstruction.
Uh,
and I hope to be able to demonstrate that on Thursday.
But I do want to get up to the point of launching a critique of structuralism on
two or three,
uh,
grounds.
Uh,
and so I hope to be able to move along fairly quickly today.
now,
uh,
another thing that got left out,
even given the proviso that it was only about,
so sir on Thursday,
uh,
was an adequate account of the relationship between synchrony and [inaudible].
Uh,
and the pivotal importance of this concept for,
uh,
not only for semiotics but for its aftermath in structuralism and also for its
relation to the Russian formulas.
Because you remember that in talking about function,
the formalist who began,
who undertook to think about literary history and the problems of literary
historiography,
we're very much engaged,
um,
in the notion that a function in a given text could be understood in two
different ways.
There was the sin function,
which was the relationship between that function and all the other functions in
the text.
In other words,
viewed as an aspect of that text.
But there was also of the same function.
It's auto function,
which is the way in which it presents and recurs throughout the history of
literature.
Sometimes as the dominant,
sometimes latent or recessive,
but always in one form or another there now.
And so it's there in linguistics.
The relationship between synchrony and I acronym is very much the same to
consider language in toto is to consider it at a given moment.
Sin Chronically.
That is to say you don't think of language as a system if at the same time
you're thinking of it unfolding historically.
Now Jakobsen you will notice introduces an element of time into this in chronic
analysis of a semiotic system by saying that you've got to take account both of
our Keck and innovative features,
but nevertheless they are simply flagged as archaic or innovative and not
understood as changing in time as long as they are read or analyzed in
chronically.
But at the same token,
a system does change through time,
a semiotic system language,
the history of literature,
the history of poetics,
whatever it might be,
changes through time and to analyze that changed through time.
You think of it dire chronically now.
So Sarah argues that the relationship among the parts of something viewed sin
chronically a semiotic system,
let's say are not necessary and the sense they might be any number of other
relationships,
but they are nevertheless fixed.
That is to say there what's there,
they can't be other than what they are.
Whereas through time studying a semiotic system or studying language or whatever
it might be,
change takes place and it's necessary.
You're looking back on it and it simply did happen and so changes determinant in
some stance but at the same time it's not regular.
This by the way is a challenge to certain ideas in traditional linguistics.
Like for example,
the one you probably all know the great vol shift,
they a structuralist view of language has to argue that the great,
great vol shifted,
which every vowel sound goes up a notch,
uh,
in the some mysterious period between the medieval in the early modern,
that this only has the appearance of regularity.
Ah,
but that it is actually,
uh,
a diachronic phenomenon that can't be understood,
in terms of regularity.
So the relationship between synchronic chronic and diachronic is of that kind.
Now matters are complicated a little bit on those occasions in your reading when
people are talking about the way in which a mass of material,
a system of language or other semiotics system,
let's say is inferred from existing data.
In other words,
the way in which I infer language long from sentences poll from us sentence
barrel.
Uh,
I'm actually concealing from you that in fact,
so sewer uses a third term long gosh to talk about the sum of all sentences.
We won't get into that.
Uh,
the way in which language is inferred from patrol.
Now language in other words is viewed as something in space that is to say,
or as Levy Strauss calls it,
a revertible time.
Meaning you can go backward and forward within it,
but the temporal unfolding is not the important thing about it.
So in space,
whereas parole speech unfolds in time.
So that power all because it is temporal,
because any speech any of us makes is in a certain sense.
Historical at the beginning of the sentence is earlier in history.
Then the end of the sentence for that reason,
there's a relationship between Dayak honey and the unfolding of Powell,
or of a sentence or of an utterance.
Um,
which is a parallel though at the same time,
admittedly confusing one doesn't really want to talk about a sentence as
diachronic,
but at the same time,
it does exist on that horizontal axis,
enrich things in a combinatory way unfold in time.
All right,
so,
so much then,
uh,
for synchrony and I acronym is something that we can't get away from.
It's,
it's,
it's in a way the central fact of structuralism,
uh,
but which I don't think I did adequate justice justice too at the end of the
last lecture.
All right.
Now structuralism
there was an incredible aura about structuralism in the 1960s.
It crashed on the shores of the United States coming in from France.
Uh,
in a way that stunned,
amazed,
transformed people's lives.
Uh,
people,
uh,
like caught reading Hume woke up from their dogmatic slumbers or they,
or at least that they felt that that's what they were doing when encountering
structuralism.
Uh,
and I mean,
to me it happened when I was a graduate student at Harvard and absolutely nobody
else was paying any attention to it at all at Yale and Johns Hopkins and Cornell
and some other people,
they were paying attention to it.
But at Harvard,
I was initiated to structuralism by a bright undergraduate who seemed to be the
only,
the only person in Cambridge who knew anything about structuralism in board did
he know about structuralism and got me up to speed as quickly as as he could.
But it was a phenomenon,
uh,
that was transformative intellectually for people,
in the academic and beyond the academic world all over the country.
And of course,
it led to,
in all sorts of ways to most of what's been going on in theory ever since.
The amazing thing about it is that as a flourishing and undisputed French
contribution to literary theory,
it lasted two years,
uh,
because in 1966 at a famous conference,
Jacques Derrida who will be reading,
uh,
on Thursday blew it out of the water.
Um,
but at the same time,
um,
and I'll come back to that,
uh,
at the same time that is,
I mean to say that it really only lasted two years,
simply isn't fair.
The lasting contribution of structuralism,
uh,
as it's indebted to semiotics,
but on its own terms at well,
it something one still feels and senses,
uh,
throughout literary theory and the concrete contributions.
Um,
not all,
uh,
between 1964 when the first structure was texts were translated in this country
in 1966 when the conference in Baltimore,
uh,
took place.
Um,
but the lasting concrete contributions are also terribly important.
There's a wonderful book called Andris on Racine by rolling back.
Those of you interested in French neoclassical theater cannot imagine,
uh,
if you haven't read it already recently reading a more bracing book,
there is a,
an essay on a Sonnet abode layer Laisha the cats,
uh,
by written conjointly by Levy Strauss and Jaco Epson,
an extraordinary performance,
which was the model of a good deal else that was done in the academy during that
period.
The anthropologist,
Edmund Leash leak,
wrote a structuralist analysis of genesis in the Bible and indeed it's no
accident that he writes about genesis as I will indicate in a minute and then
subsequently,
um,
and,
uh,
and in addition to all of that,
probably the most lasting and rich contributions of the structuralist.
We're in the field,
uh,
that we know as narrow tology.
We'll be taking a look at that when we read.
Uh,
Peter Brooks is taxed and compete in conjunction with Freud a couple of weeks
from now.
But in the meantime,
uh,
the key text and neurotology again by role are embarked a long,
long essay called the structural analysis of narrative in which he approaches a
James Bond novel as a system system of binary pairs,
uh,
and uh,
and,
and unpacks a deep structure,
uh,
and the novel,
as a result of this,
uh,
of this,
of this binary analysis,
uh,
important books by its fate on toter off,
crucial among them,
uh,
the grammar of the Decameron,
and then a great deal of work published in a series of books called figure by
genre.
Jeanette,
whom you will find quoted,
uh,
repeatedly in the work of Paul demand that you'll be reading for,
for next,
uh,
Tuesday.
Uh,
and all of this work,
uh,
and a great deal else in the theory of narrative narrow tology,
is directly indebted to or is actually an aspect of structuralist thought.
Now,
I promised that I would talk a little bit about the relationship between
formalism and Sammy Audix as it clarifies itself in the work of a writer's like
Levy Strauss and in particular Yaka person structuralism takes from,
as you can see from Yacob sins analysis,
uh,
takes from formalism.
The idea of function,
uh,
Yaka,
is originally of course himself,
uh,
a member of the school of Russian formalists,
eventually emigrates to Prague where he is in a circle of people who are already
calling themselves structuralists moves from there to Paris and then to the
United States.
Uh,
and so y'all,
Gibson of course,
is the one figure who definitely,
uh,
hearkens back to both worlds having been a formalist,
having become a structuralist.
One can see the amalgam of these,
two of these two sets of ideas in his work and his work,
uh,
from formal.
It's from,
from formalism.
Then you get the idea of function and the relationship between sin functioning
auto function,
which becomes the relationship between synchrony and Diane acronym from
semiotics.
You get the idea of negative knowledge.
That is to say that in Levy Strauss is analysis of the edifice myth,
for example,
the notion that there is no true version,
there's no originary version.
There's no sort of positive version of the myth of which everything else is
aversion.
You simply know what you know as it is differentiated from the other things that
you know,
this one of the essential premises of semiotics,
uh,
which is essential at the same time,
in structuralism now unlike because here's where structuralism can be understood
as an entity in itself.
Unlike formalism,
structuralism has an ambition with respect to the object to the nature of the
object,
which is quite new.
And I think that the best way to,
uh,
epitomize that is to turn to an aphorism of roll on back in the essay,
the structuralist activity on page eight 71 toward the bottom of the right hand
column where back says structural man takes the real decomposes it then
recomposes it.
This is the moment in which you can see the radical difference between what
structuralism is doing and what formalism is doing.
Formalism takes the object and it doesn't decompose it,
it sees the object as it is.
It just breaks it down into its respective functions,
showing them dynamically in relationship with each other.
Uh,
and as a,
as a system of dominance and subordination,
uh,
all of it understood as the way in which something is made,
the way in which it is put together.
But there's no question of,
of,
of anything other than the object go goals.
Overcoat Covanta has don Quixote,
Sterns,
Tristram Shandy.
These are objects and there's no question of somehow or another creating a
virtual object,
for example,
the novel,
uh,
out of one's remarks about individual text.
In a way though.
That's what,
as you can see again from Levi Strauss's analysis of the Oedipus myth.
That's what structuralism is doing.
As Beck says,
structural man takes the real,
decomposes it then recomposes it.
So what he means by that is you take a bunch of variants version,
you take a bunch of data,
not necessarily all the data,
but a representative amount of the data relevant to any given idea or concept.
And then you say,
well what are the,
and this is where he,
he,
he gets into the idea of this is where he gets into the idea of gross
constituent units.
What are the basic constituent units of all of these items of data?
Oh yeah,
I see.
We can put them into a pattern.
What we'll work on this a little bit in a minute.
Ah,
yeah.
I see how this is working.
As a matter of fact,
there is a kind of virtual object that I can begin to observe as I organize the
data that I garner from all the individual entities are versions that,
that,
that fall under this umbrella.
And that's the recomposition
not of any particular object,
but of a kind of virtual object which begins to emerge from ones in analysis.
In the case of Levy Strauss is text the meaning of the Oedipus Smith.
That's the virtual object that structuralist analysis arrives at.
By arranging,
analyzing and classifying the data that it can get from all the available
versions of the Oedipus.
So structuralism decomposes but not just for the sake of seeing how something
works,
like taking apart the parts of an engine,
not just to see how something works,
but in order to lend the parts to an analysis of a,
of,
of a body of materials that makes it possible to re compose all those parts in a
new virtual object.
That's what's going on in,
uh,
what box calls the structuralist activity.
So quickly,
let's take a look at the levy Strauss,
a chart,
if you ought to call it that,
of the Oedipus myth,
which is on page eight 64 in your text and just say a word or two about it.
He takes a lot of versions.
Let's not trouble ourselves with how many,
he doesn't have nearly as many versions by the way,
as he would have if he were studying,
uh,
North American Indian myth,
or a,
or the sorts of myths that he did study in a variety of versions as an
anthropologist.
But he has some versions.
One of them,
by the way,
Freud's version,
uh,
one of them Sophocles version,
and a variety of versions,
uh,
besides those.
And he says,
hmm,
you know,
as you look at these various versions,
you can see that certain things are basically happening and they fall into
certain discreet categories.
We can put them in columns.
That is to say in terms of the way in which they share a common theme,
but we can also put those columns in a row so that we can in that,
so that we can analyze the way in which the columns relate to each other.
For example,
there's a group of events happenstances,
uh,
sort of naming accidents and so on,
that falls into a common,
a column called over determination of blood relations.
Uh,
that is to say when,
um,
when Antigony tries to bury her brother and goes to the wall for that in ways
that you might find excessive,
that's an overdetermined and determination of blood relations,
uh,
then,
and then you noticed that at the same time,
there's a series of actions in the myths going all the way back to edit
[inaudible] family history and then down through the history of his offspring.
And so on that there's also a series of actions which have to do with the
undervaluation of blood relations.
You know,
people,
well,
they don't really seem to care as much about blood relations as they should.
Uh,
and as a result of that,
uh,
bad things happen to,
and then there's a,
and then there's a column of,
of issues which have to do with the way in which recurrently,
in all the versions of the myth,
there seems to be a strange preoccupation with that,
which is born from the earth monsters.
Uh,
um,
you know,
the teeth of monsters that are scattered and become the alphabet,
uh,
in the story of Cadmus and,
the variety of ways in which heroes have to confront monsters as Oedipus
confronts the state,
the Sphinx,
and all of these monsters are,
are understood as not being born from parents as being born from two things.
But instead,
as emerging from the earth,
they are phonic or,
or toxin us in Levis.
Strauss is word.
And there seems to be a strange preoccupation with the OT,
with [inaudible] in this myth.
But this is,
but,
but this is offset by the way in which,
uh,
but by the,
by the way in which,
um,
that is to say with fending off all toxins as if the crucial thing where to
incest on the binary parental relationship that produces us to be reassured in
our humanity by the idea that one of us is born from two.
But then on the other hand,
there are all kinds of things in the myth which are also preoccupied with all
taught,
with all toxin and precisely the opposite way.
Uh,
lambda,
uh,
the word that begins so many of the names of the figures in edifices genealogy
lab,
Dacher's latest and so on.
Lambda looks like a limping person,
right?
Oedipus means swell foot one who limps.
Uh,
and what emerges in the fourth column is the idea that there are signs of
autocross honey in our own makeup.
The reason we limp is that we have a foot of clay,
that something of the earth from which we were born sticks to us.
And this is a recurrent pattern,
a recurrent idea in the unfolding of the Oedipus myth.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it's a peculiar thing,
but notice that this is one of those occasions on which the myth explodes into
other cultures.
Adam means red clay.
Adam is born from the earth in the sense that red clay is taken from the earth
and he is created and there seems to be the same preoccupation with autocracy
honey in the Oedipus myth as well.
One of the interesting links of that myth with,
uh,
the Christian myth of the origin of man.
So you got four columns,
overvaluation of blood relations,
undervaluation of blood relations,
denial of all and the presidents of all talk.
Funny.
All right,
I'm going to leave it at that for now because we'll come back later to see what
interesting thing is going on in the way in which these four columns are all
about two versus one.
That is to say whether or not,
uh,
we are born from two or born from one.
And I want to come back to that,
to,
to that in the context of showing that in a certain way,
the question whether things come from to ideas,
for example,
come from to two different things or whether ideas come from one object is after
all,
this question is itself an allegory of the structuralist activity.
That's what structuralism itself is about.
And that's what makes it so interesting and even perhaps peculiar that Levy
Strauss is able to defer to find not just any thought in a myth,
but the very,
that he himself is doing about the myth.
So,
and that of course may have something to do with your sense that surely
decomposing in order to wreak and stroke recomposed creating a virtual systemic
object,
notice that I've made this a dotted line creating a virtual systemic object,
um,
that there's a kind of a circularity in that,
you know,
you look at,
I mean,
I hope I've explained a Levy Strauss has four columns.
Intelligibly but if you look at those four columns,
you just say to yourself,
how on earth did he come up with that,
you know?
And he himself says,
oh,
well maybe I could have done it some other way.
Oh,
you know,
and uh,
and was,
and you say to yourself,
how can this become decisive?
How can it become authoritative?
I,
um,
you can see what he's doing.
And by the way,
you can confirm it by thinking of things that he leaves out.
Jocasta hangs herself.
He doesn't mention that it's not in any of the four columns,
but obviously that has something to do.
You can take your choice either between the over determination or under
determination of blood relations.
She feels guilty because she committed incest,
right?
Oedipus well at his birth is hamstrung and exposed on Mount Catherine at
[inaudible].
Strauss doesn't mention that either,
but obviously that's why had a piss limps.
Oedipus is a limping person liked the letter lambda,
right?
And so plainly,
that must have something to do with the persistence of all talk.
Funny.
And finally,
if you read the Oedipus Coladas,
you know that at the end of it,
Oedipus when he dies is swallowed up by the earth.
Dust Thou art to dust,
thou shall return the this,
the,
the equivalent of this in the Oedipus myth as that where I came from,
the earth is where I will go.
And he becomes a kind of a genius of the place at Coladas.
As a result of having been swallowed up there,
he becomes a kind of,
uh,
presiding spirit or genius of the place.
So all of those things,
which we ourselves thought of,
uh,
he didn't think of him.
He didn't put them in.
You didn't put them in.
His diagram can,
however,
be put in his diagram.
And if that's the case,
we have to say to ourselves,
hmm,
there might be something in this.
Maybe,
maybe this is a plausible and interesting way of arranging these materials.
So I really do think that ought to be said in defense of what may seem,
uh,
however,
to be a somewhat arbitrary exercise now turning [inaudible]
you may say with all this emphasis I've been throwing on decomposing in order to
recomposed that you don't see that going on in what Jakobsen it saying,
you may say to yourself,
well,
he seems to be just doing formalism.
You know,
he breaks,
he breaks any speech,
act into its,
into six functions.
He talks about the Inter determinacy of those six functions,
uh,
with a certain result that sounds just like formulas and you say,
well,
um,
one way to show the way in which [inaudible] has been and is doing his
structuralist is to say that after all in this essay,
uh,
there's a lot more of this.
I,
by the way,
what's your editor doesn't give you,
it's mostly about diversification,
which is,
uh,
the longstanding specialty of Yacob Upson's work,
Russian versification check risk location.
And so on.
Um,
and a little technical,
but it is all about the poetic function.
After all this essay is about the poetic function,
what the formalist would call literariness,
but Yaka Basin has a real contribution to make to this notion of the poetic
function.
And what it is is basically this,
the product function,
and I'm going to quote this for the first time.
It's on page eight 58 in the left hand column and it's a mouthful.
The poetic function projects,
the principle of equivalents from the axis of selection to the access of
combination.
Now you understand the poetic function projects,
the principle of equivalent from the axis of selection to the access of
combination.
What is the principle of equivalents?
You've got that you've got a good deal of it.
The privilege,
the principle of equivalent can be understood as what Jaco Epson and the Aphasia
Essay calls metaphor.
That is to say the way in which you remember.
You remember last time I talked about how signs cluster on the verdict in the
vertical axis.
If we understand languages,
the system,
there are some signs that relate the signs in ways that they probably don't
relate to yet.
Other signs.
And then I had an incredible lapse of memory.
I couldn't remember a synonym for ship,
but I still hope that I got,
I still got my,
I hope that I got my point across to you.
Uh,
and indicated that there are varieties of ways in which any given sign cluster
with other signs,
those ways of clustering are what [inaudible] calls the principal of
equivalents.
What is it?
Well,
it's the way in which signs either are similar to each other or are dissimilar
to each other.
If that sounds too vague,
maybe it's better not to use language of difference or a similarity,
but actually to use language of opposition.
In other words,
the way in which signs are virtually synonymous or the way in which signs are
really and truly opposed to each other.
Obviously it stretches at just as in versification,
you don't just have full rhyme,
you have slat rhyme.
These relationships stretch in,
in,
in the,
in a v in varieties of ways of this kind.
But the principle of a kid of,
of equivalents is the way in which signs,
uh,
understood.
As phonemes Lek seems tag means however you want to understand them.
The way in which signs are similar or dissimilar.
They the,
the,
the readiness with which we combined signs of that kind is what a person
attending to the poetic function looks for.
If the utterance seems to involve a predominance of equivalences of various
kinds,
then this utterance which is unfolding on the access of combination,
right,
is the result of having projected that principle of equivalents,
call it metaphor,
call it a principle of similar similarity or dissimilarity too from the access
of selection.
That is to say that access,
perhaps a virtual one in which language is a system to the axis of combination.
That real access because nobody doubts to the existence of speech.
That real access in which language is not assistant but has become speech
unfolding in time.
The principle of the poetic function,
however,
can be understood then as the metaphorization
of what is otherwise met anemic.
In other words,
if I put together a sentence,
what I'm doing is I'm putting words next to each other,
and that's what my autonomy is at Ventana me is the,
is,
is the,
a selection of signs,
if you will,
uh,
that go appropriately next to each other according to the rules of grammar and
syntax according according to the rules of logic,
right?
Uh,
at,
but also perhaps,
uh,
in the ways in which the rent,
the rhetorical devices [inaudible] autonomy can be understood.
Um,
if I say,
I mean,
if,
if I say a hot instead of house,
I'm using an example of actually taken from Yacob sins,
Aphasia Essay.
If I say hot instead of house,
and if I say the hut is small,
um,
there is a metro Nimic relationship implied with,
uh,
houses,
shacks,
uh,
mansions,
other sorts of edifice,
but which can only really be resolved perhaps by the unfolding of the logic of
the sentence.
Uh,
as in,
when I say the Hud is small,
um,
and so common combinatory processes borrowing the rhetorical term Mytonomy as
that which is next to each other are basically met an emic.
The available signs to be selected.
On the other hand,
on the access of selection are selected for certain purposes.
If they are metaphoric.
Obviously if I'm just making a sentence,
I'm not selecting signs because they're metaphoric on selected because I
selected because they go easily next to each other either for reasons of grammar
or syntax or logic.
Now let's look at [inaudible] six functions taken all together.
I think this is by no means difficult and I think that Jaak Gibson's analysis of
the six functions is just absolutely,
totally brilliant.
In fact,
I think,
I think that,
I mean I'm so profoundly convinced by what your cups and says about these six
functions that I really think there's,
there isn't much else to say about an utterance.
I obviously in different registers,
there's lots to say.
Ah,
but in the spirit of the AUC of Sony and analysis,
there's,
there's really pot,
there's no possible you can complain,
you can make about this except possibly want,
which I probably won't get to until next time.
But in the meantime,
it's just staggeringly effective.
And let me use the example of a word of it,
of an expression,
which is surely as uninteresting.
I,
I've groped as,
as,
as much as I could to find the most uninteresting possible expression to show
the way in which any utterance whatsoever ha entails these six functions.
It is raining.
Oh boy.
Excitement reigns as they say.
So in any case,
um,
let's say,
let's say that I am an addressor,
that is to say I,
I'm a romantic poet and I say I probably ill advisedly if I'm a poet,
but I'm a romantic poet and I say,
you know,
sort of waking everybody up.
When I say it,
it is raining,
Huh?
All right.
What do I mean,
what do I mean?
If I'm a romantic poet,
I what I'm,
what I mean to say is I'm singing in the rain or it's raining in my heart and
other words I'm expressing,
I'm expressing something emotional in saying it is raining.
So that sense of the expression it is rainy is what [inaudible] calls the
emotive function.
Now I'm being addressed.
The thrust of the message is toward the dressy.
It's being spoken by an a dresser,
but it's aimed at and address dressy.
That address.
He is a small child going out the door without his coat on and his mother or
father says it is raining.
Right.
Which means of course as a cognitive function,
as a command,
as something which has a design on the address.
See what it means is put your coat on but you don't necessarily say put your
coat on.
You say it is raining and that's the cognitive function.
That's the at what y'all comes and calls the set to the addressee.
That is to say the basic dominant bearing that the message has.
The set is a set to the address.
See now there's a context for any utterance this much.
I suppose none of us would think to disagree with,
I'm a weatherman.
I'm a meteorologist,
right?
I don't even have to look out the window.
I look at my charts and I,
and I announced a confidently through the microphone.
It is raining.
All right.
And,
uh,
everybody takes me seriously.
I mean it's,
it,
the referential function of it is raining,
is supposed to convey information.
I'm a weatherman.
I'm supposed to know what I'm talking about.
So if somebody,
so if a weatherman tells me it is ranting,
I believe that it is raining.
I put my hand out the door and sure enough,
it is raining and the referential function,
the dominant in the expression,
it is raining,
uh,
as referential function,
has been confirmed.
I don't expect the Weatherman to be set to,
to,
to be telling me somehow,
secretly that he's crying when he says it is raining.
Right?
I expect him,
I expect him to tell me the truth about the weather.
Right?
And that's what,
and that's what I'm listening to him for.
All right.
Now the set to the contact y'all comes and gives you that.
Those wonderful examples from a Dorothy Parker's representation of a date.
Jeff,
whoa boy.
Well,
here we are.
Yeah,
we sure are here.
Uh,
and so on.
Right?
Um,
in other words,
in a state of abject and acute nervousness,
filling the air with words,
right?
So that,
so that you know,
you're on a date,
right?
And you can't think of anything to say,
I really feel sorry for you.
Uh,
you're,
you're on a date and you can't think of anything to say.
Say,
say it is raining.
And of course your interlocutor says,
yeah,
it's raining.
And you say it's,
it's raining hard,
you know,
as well.
Yeah.
Maybe it'll stop soon.
And so,
you know,
and so the conversation continues and that's the phatic function.
Checking to make sure the contact is working.
Testing one,
two,
three.
Can you hear me?
That's what the set to the contact is.
Anything that confirms that you're actually sort of in communication with
somebody and anything we can say it has that component.
I mean,
if I'm a physicist and I'm going out on a date with another physicist,
I say EMC equals MC squared.
You know,
and I'm not saying e equals MC squared.
I'm filling the air with words and,
and so once again,
it's the set to the contact and any message in the right context has that
function.
The set to the code is when we're not sure that we share adequately share the
code with another person on a given occasion so that we back away from simply
saying things to make sure that what we're saying is clear and other words to
define them.
I say there's a mirror on the field.
Somebody says,
what is the mayor?
Well,
it's a female horse.
it's a female horse is the metal lingual function,
but we're talking about it is raining.
This is where it really gets interesting.
The most interesting thing about it is raining in terms of these six functions
is metal lingual because what on earth is it all right if somebody tells me it
is raining,
I say,
what?
What are you talking about?
What is it?
I don't,
I have absolutely no idea what you're saying.
I've noticed that other languages have the same weird phenomenon.
E plus s pregnant.
What on earth does any of that mean?
What does he you,
what does s,
what is it?
Is it God,
is it Jupiter,
Pluto,
[inaudible] is at the cloud canopy.
Well,
sort of as the cloud canopy,
but that's,
that's sort of clearly not what's meant by it.
Right?
It is a kind of grammatical and syntactical anomaly,
which is extremely difficult even for link for linguists to analyze and to
explain and that so that when I try to say it is raining,
I can expect the metal lingual and if,
if I'm talking to a literalist of course I kind of expect the metal lingual
function to kick in and in fact bite me in the Shin.
Uh,
it is,
it's,
it's no picnic with the metal lingual function in mind saying it is raining.
What kind of a definition of it is,
it's raining,
you know,
and so and so,
uh,
problems arise but they're interesting problems and there are a function,
one of the six functions of the expression.
It is raining.
Poetic function is unfortunately not very interesting.
That's the one,
that's the one drawback of this example,
but this is still planted to say it and the air in Ning,
which one can hear the double [inaudible] in raining?
Uh,
they,
uh,
the monosyllables I'm suggesting,
you know,
so to a kind of a quick declaration of something followed by a sense of duration
that one always feels when one is aware of rain coming at it is raining.
So that the,
uh,
so,
so that the duration or prolongation of the word has a kind of semantic value
indicating to us that this is something ongoing.
Uh,
in other words,
a variety of a variety of ways in which the poetic function of it is raining can
be considered for the poetic function to be dominant.
Um,
as I suggested when I said a romantic poet wouldn't be very smart if he or she
said it was raining for the,
for the poetic function to be dominant,
uh,
would really,
be taxing,
uh,
for anyone who wanted to make it.
So,
but it could be any function could be the dominant in a certain situation of any
given utterance.
And so,
uh,
the so,
so the,
so that then,
um,
sort of perhaps to suffice,
uh,
as an analysis of,
of,
uh,
Yaka person's understanding of the structure of an utterance.
And it has a structure in so far that is to say a metaphoric as opposed to a
metronomic structure in so far as we observe the presence of some kind of
pressure from the access of selection,
the principle of equivalents and the access of selection bringing itself to bear
on the way in which the combination takes place.
It's just incredible that,
you know,
you say it is very,
what could be more Prozac then hit his writing and all of a sudden you've
noticed that string of eyes,
you notice all kinds of other things about it.
I mean,
it is,
it is the,
the,
the way in which the most basal utterance is combined is likely in one form or
another almost unavoidable.
I suppose I should use the strong argument and say unavoidably is likely
unavoidably to entail aspect of the poetic function where the poetic function is
dominant.
You have literariness.
And that of course is the old object of scientific attention of the Russian
formalists.
But it is a refined in a way that I think is structuralist by aqua button
because he insists on the binary nature
of the process of combining elements from the access of selection if they are
equivalent,
binary being same,
opposite,
similar dissimilar and the variety of patterns in which,
uh,
those relations same opposite,
similar dissimilar can be launched into use.
Now
I've actually reached the point at which,
uh,
act at which possibly I could,
um,
get involved,
uh,
in some elements of critique.
Uh,
and I suppose I'll begin.
I may not finish,
but we can always carry over in,
into the next lecture.
So since we've been talking about your cuffs and let me call your attention to
one problem in what seems to me otherwise to be a truly remarkable exercise of
thought.
And that problem arises on page eight 58
and he himself recognizes that it's a problem.
He acknowledges it's a problem,
but he wants to say that he's solved it and saying what he says.
It's about,
it's a,
it's,
it's about two thirds of the way down the page and it's about the relationship
between the poetic function and the metal lingual function between the set to
the message and the set to the code as he puts it.
And this is what he said.
It may be objective.
Yeah,
and here we are objecting,
right.
It may be objected that metalanguage also makes a sequential use of equivalent
units when combining Sinan emic expressions into an equational sentence.
A equals a mayor is the female of the horse poetry and metalanguage,
however,
are in Diab diametrical opposition to each other.
They're not the same right there in diametrical opposition to each other and
metal language.
The sequence is used to build an equation.
In other words,
to prove that two things are that,
that that one,
that that one term can be understood in terms of other terms.
The sequence is used to build an equip.
Whereas in poetry,
the equation is used to build a sequence.
Okay.
Now in one sense,
this is true,
obviously.
Yes,
that is,
I know what I'm speaking mental language,
and I know when I'm speaking poetry,
maybe you know it too,
but what y'all Gibson has actually done is he's sort of exposed a structuralist
nerve because he has appealed to intention.
That is to say,
he said the metal lingual expression has one intention and the poetic expression
has another intention.
What does that mean?
It has a genesis.
It has an origin in an intending consciousness,
just as in traditions,
not structuralist.
Things have origins in prior causes and not in their structural relationship
between two things.
In other words,
if structuralism is a critique of genesis,
as light as is the case with Edmund leashes,
analysis of the biblical text,
genesis as is the case,
uh,
certainly with love and Strauss is understanding of the Oedipus myth from to and
not from one.
If structuralism is a critique of Genesis,
what happens?
Why don't you have to make a distinction between two entities in your system?
The poetic function and the metal lingual function in terms of their genesis.
That is to say in terms of the intention that stands behind them.
As I said,
the example seems trivial because we're all more than to agree with [inaudible]
that we know the difference when we see it between the metal lingual and the
poetic functions.
But he's not actually saying we know the difference when we see it.
Maybe it would have been better if he had said it.
Well anybody can see what's metal lingual.
It was poetic.
Maybe you know,
maybe it would have been better if he had what he says instead is metal lingual
is intended to do one thing.
Poetic is intended to do another thing that that opens actually a can of worms
about all six functions.
You know,
I stand here in front of you and I say it is raining.
How do you know which,
what I'm intending,
right.
Whether I'm nervous and sort of sort of just being phatic whether I,
whether I am really unhappy or happy,
you know,
whether I think you're crazy.
It is in fact raining outside and I don't see any coats,
uh,
whether I am actually,
sort of just masquerading as an English professor.
I'm really a meteorologist.
I mean,
how do you,
you don't,
you don't know any of these things.
You have to infer an intention.
All right?
And if you infer an intention,
uh,
in order to make,
in order to make these distinctions,
um,
how can the structuralist imperative of structure rather than Janet Genesis be
preserved intact?
How can we incest that we know negative things negatively and not positively if
we have to infer a direct cause,
a positive cause in order to grasp distinctions even between the six functions?
That's a rhetorical question with which I don't necessarily agree.
Uh,
but it is a potential objection that,
that you may wish to explore on your own.
Now,
the critique of Levy Strauss,
I've already hinted that,
um,
uh,
but there's another aspect of it too that I will defer until next time because
you'll find that dairy does that.
The Essay of Derrida that you're reading,
uh,
is largely about levies Strauss.
So we'll make a natural segway between what we're talking about today and what
we'll be talking about Thursday to return first to certain aspects of Strauss
Strauss's argument.
And then,
uh,
and then get going with what dairy does say.
Thank you.
See that.